Many people
think how can they achieve happiness and
the most common that men think is if
you're rich you'll get happiness. So
something wealth will bring you
happiness.
Something power will bring you
happiness. Something that fame
and popularity will bring you happiness.
Something the more number of friends
will get you happiness. Different people
have different
standard of achieving happiness. But let
me tell you
all these happiness few may fall in
category one. The remaining fall in
category two. You may think becoming a
rich man by becoming a millionaire or
billionaire you'll be happy. If you see
the statistics of today's most richest
men, Elon Musk, Jeff Bisos, Bill Gates,
all of them divorced.
Some of the children they filed a suit
against their father in the court. Is
this happiness? The husband and wife
fighting.
Imagine richest man.
All of them have been richest at least
once.
So this is a false perception. someone
power.
I want to become a leader. I want to be
a minister. I want to be a prime
minister. I want to be a president.
After that, what
does it achieve happiness? Someone to
become famous. Why? I want such a big
following. I want to have 1 million
people on the social media. I want 5
million people on the social media. On
the Facebook 10 million after that, what
does that following get you happiness?
If yes, maybe you may get elited. Ah,
I've got 10 million followers. You may
think you're great. After that, what?
Someone friends. Okay, you throw money
and you get many friends.
After that, what? So all these are
temporary happens.
And our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said
a man would want if Allah subhanana wa
tala gives a value of gold to a human
being he would want a second you know
value of gold no human being in the
world owns a value of gold even Elon
Musk doesn't own a value of gold
says if Allah gives him a second one he
would want a third
only a fistful of dust is sufficient
to fill the belly of a human being. So
whatever wealth you have, you will never
be
wealth.
Even if you're the most richest man in
the world, you'll never be satisfied.
You Allah gives you a value of all, you
want two value. Allah gives you two, you
want a third, yet you'll never be
satisfied. Happiness comes not from
absence of conflict in life. It comes
from the ability to cope with it.
Let me repeat. Happiness comes not from
absence of problems in life. It comes
from the ability to cope with it. That's
the reason the best and the true
happiness can only be achieved by
following the guidelines of the glorious
Quran, the last and final revelation of
Almighty God, Allah subhana wa t'ala and
the teachings of the last and final
messenger, prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. The only way you can get
ultimate happiness is by following the
glorious Quran and the authentic hadith
because these are the only source that
gives you ultimate and complete
happiness. Others may give you temporary
happiness may give you one problem.
These two are the only sources in the
world today that will give you complete
and absolute and eternal happiness.
Allah says in the Quran in surah mulk
chapter number 67 verse number two
Allah has created death and life to test
which of his good indeeds. So when you
go back to the definition of the
psychologist they say it's a continuous
feeling
of enjoyment of delight of satisfaction
of generosity
and about eternal bliss and destiny.
They're talking about future also.
So happiness is MORE OF A STATE of mind.
says a state of wellbeing and content.